nearly 28 million americans suffer from
copd a condition that makes it quite
often very difficult to breathe and just
to go about everyday activities to talk
more about that we are joined by
intermountain healthcare dr suresh tani
who is a pulmonary physician at
intermountain healthcare thank you so
much for being here dr thank you thank
you thanks for watching this let's break
it down what is copd
so copd stands for chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease
it's a chronic it's a very common
respiratory condition
the copd actually is a preventable and
treatable disease
you know and it is caused by because
there's a damage to the bronchial tubes
and the alveoli
and this and because of that patients
have persistent respiratory symptoms
like shortness of breath cough tiredness
of fatigue so how does one know that
they have that is it something you have
to go through tasks to make to determine
if you truly have that so when you see a
medical provider
you have like a history examination and
then you have to go for a breathing test
called a spirometric test as a breathing
test is a pretty simple test it's a
painless test which is performed by a
medical care professional person in
which you're breathing through a tube
and then you blow out as hard as you can
into the tube yeah yeah and at
intermountain healthcare you have a
whole team that works
so one patient gets to see a lot of
different people and that's great
because you have different minds joining
in that's correct yeah yeah and what are
some ways to prevent copd i mean the
main thing that eighty percent of
patients united states who have a copd
they have a history of smoking
cigarettes
so you know that cigarette is the main
cause for this copd so main thing is to
avoid those cigarette smoking also the
from air pollution
also exposure to the chemical dust or
fumes
at in your job as well as into the
outside you know that can also cause
copd too we mentioned the millions of
americans who are dealing with this is
the number increasing after covet is
that a a byproduct of covet of course
definitely because of covada also kobe
doesn't cause copd but is a risk factor
any kind of infection can also cause you
know as a risk factor for copd yeah so
it opens the door for that what are some
things people should know about it that
maybe they don't know otherwise
i mean if you're getting like if you
have a risk factor like a cigarette
smoking and you're getting tired fatigue
you're having a cough
with some sputum production you're
getting some wheezing
you know we would suggest that you
should also get a medical attention for
that
we mentioned the team that they uh
patients deal with at intermountain
healthcare who are these people and what
are the different roles they play so in
our medical the copd clinic team you
know we have medical provider which is
me
then we have a nursing manager who has
expertise in disease management we have
two respiratory therapists we have one
care manager
we have one medical assistant and one
care manager assistant so it's like a
team of six seven people together
working together and so are treatments
advanced enough that the symptoms can be
alleviated
or is it just something that is
diminished once you have copd i mean
it's symptoms of diminishes the patient
can breathe better actually you know so
they are like most of the time you give
them some kind of inhalers you know yeah
to improve their symptoms we also send
the patient for rehab we also give make
sure the patient gets vaccinated
for the flu vaccination pneumonia
vaccine covered vaccine in a tdap
we send the patient for rehab
we also have the patient who might need
some oxygen
so all those things can make a huge
difference in the lives of patients dr
tawny thank you so much for being here
today i really appreciate it thank you
inviting us
thanks again to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring this segment if you'd
like more information or if you want to
make an appointment you can visit the
webpage that is listed right there on
your screen
intermountain healthcare.org slash
nevada we'll be right back